carl what occurs to you when you hear
that
um
ambiguity um
again sort of um
just thinking about the imperatives for
self-organization
so
when i hear that was a fascinating story
um and don't let me forget we ought to
explain to the viewers what babbling
means just in this context as well
because that's quite illuminating
perhaps we can i'm not sure that the
cells do do motor babbling um but they
certainly resolve um the same kind of
problem um so my um chris correct me if
i'm wrong but
by babbling all we mean is that when
you're
first born into any universe
you've got to um
work out or test the hypothesis that i
cause that or the world caused that
so you don't know you don't have a self
model you don't you know
whether this is sort of
a declarative model it's completely
subpersonal just um hardwired into the
um the synaptic efficacy and
connectivity of your brain
so the first thing you have to do is
just to work out what you can control
and what you can't control
and the idea is that you you
engage in
what i would call epistemic or respond
to epistemic affordances or epistemic
plans that reveal knowledge they resolve
uncertainty and in this instance it's
the uncertainty about whether
i was the cause of this rattle rattling
so if you imagine um motor babbling
as
manifest in a little baby
you know rattling its rattle
generating both the sensations from the
muscles and the skin but also the visual
and the auditory sensations all co-occur
providing definitive evidence that
there's something special about
this process and this event
that um
that provides the basis for the
hypothesis there's a unitary cause
there's a unitary cause which is me
shaking the rattle
but of course it may take several months
if not years to actually get there to
actually realize that causes me so one
can imagine sort of you know robots
learning about
the uh the manipulator that they can
articulate all the the way in which they
can move around and you know um
for ambulate um but i think the idea
bring it back to sort of where the self
had come from um
it would um
rest upon
the testing the hypothesis which has to
be physically represented with a deep
more complex genetic model and sense
making um that in fact it's me that's
actually caused this single cause of all
these proprioceptive
motor sensations visual sensations
auditory sensations um and that will be
especially prescient when you're
starting to realize that some of these
causes which you thought were you
of the sort associated with nurturing
and suckling um were actually due to mum
and we come back to this argument to to
actually have a good hypothesis which
explains why i am not in charge of mum
because she is now not always responding
to me when i cry
to explain that i have to now develop a
hypothesis yes it was me causing all of
this um but sometimes there's something
else else out there that's not me but
very much like me and that's mum and
then you can see how there would be a
pressure
in terms of you know finding the best
explanations for your sensations to to
have that so if you take that notion now
think of the same problem uh from the
point of view of a cell
um you know what are the impairment of a
bunch of cells that have to work
together or will ultimately
form a
an embryo
via this process of symmetry breaking
you you know you have to ask what are
the underlying imperatives how how could
it be any other way um and of course it
could be more like i said it could be
lots of ways but
the ways the ways in which it goes wrong
um which would be another way of saying
um those rare occasions or the the ways
that it doesn't happen in
in consequence of their rarity um
involve this ambiguity again
literally in this in the context of some
cells not knowing whether they're
belonging to one twin or or another twin
from the from the cell's perspective
um
so um i was just thinking about the
nature of ambiguity and of course you
know it is exactly the same
um
one can account
for
the
simple observation that
self-organization
does not tolerate ambiguity does not
tolerate uncertainty
it's only um manifest in the context of
accurate and
well evidenced definitive
exchanges so come back to chris's notion
of you know sense making
projecting onto my markov blanket or my
holographic screen from the point of
view of the quantum formulation
that i need to resolve all the
uncertainty
as much uncertainty as i can but put
that another way
um as in a more slightly more
deflationary way stuff which we see the
way the universe seems to work
is um
can be described as
realizing processes that minimize this
this kind of uncertainty and ambiguity
and simply maximize the mutual
predictability of what's being projected
or impressed upon my surface on my
holographic screen or my markov blanket
so i you know that's what i was that was
going through my mind i thought it was a
beautiful example of of you know uh when
it goes wrong the the the the the
uncertainty in ambiguity
in the game and uh and that tells you
something quite fundamental about when
it goes right and when it goes right
it's just basically um a statement of
what exists or what you know what what
perseveres
over time chris did you have anything to
say to add to that
well i would be interested to uh
to see how actually
how
mike responds to
that uh
discourse with respect to the example of
this embryonic sheet where
the cells are each trying to figure out
what they're supposed to do
uh
and
there's they're still
uh
they still certainly believe that they
should be reproducing so they they
definitely do that and they signal to
each other but somehow their
the collective effect of all of that
signaling to each other
is to organize different roles for them
for each for themselves
so how does the symmetry breaking occur
yeah so so that's that's really
interesting so as i was hearing um carl
talk about this i realized a couple of
things that um first of all uh as we
were saying before feedback loops are
absolutely central to this process
because the easiest way to prevent any
of this from happening and to end up
with a uh uh um kind of a mono um you
know sort of uh uh you know a very a
featureless sheet where there are no
embryos is to block that is to block the
positive feedback loop that we had so so
that long that that short range
inhibition long-range activation that
says to one cell i'm going to now be the
organizer i'm going to make this access
everybody else don't do it you those are
both feedback loops and so if you break
those feedback loops you get nothing so
so the feedback loops are right at the
beginning of this process and and the
other thing that that i thought was
really interesting that carl just said
is about the cells babbling so what i
think
it's a really good name for what we see
when you take a cell and you put it out
into a dish
what you'll see
and in fact in any in any new
environment you will see two things that
i think are probably babbling in
different spaces one is that in physical
space you will see that it's incredibly
active it's constantly putting out and
pulling back these these um
kind of extensions so these cytoplasmic
extensions that have all kinds of
sensors on them they're not just sitting
the cell is never just sitting there
waiting for something to happen it's
constantly probing its environment it's
incredibly active i'm sure it's taking
all kinds of energy uh it costs to to do
all this um there are videos of it that
are just remarkable on online and you
know we see them every day the other the
other babbling takes place in
transcriptional space so gene expression
is also never just sort of still and
this is you know these are the genes
that are expressed and i'm just going to
sit here and do that all the genes are
constantly going up and down within
specific ranges as it sort of wiggles in
this transcriptional space and i think
both of them probably physiologically
metabolically i bet this is going on in
all these other spaces and i think
babbling is an excellent uh framework
for for understanding what it's actually
doing it's actually taking these little
actions looking for evidence of specific
things that it can then make use of to
start to draw you know to draw
boundaries and and as chris as chris was
saying i think what happens is that in
this blastoderm you get
uh
what what will happen is that once once
that that individuation starts where
there's a specific cell that starts to
go down this road of uh being the
organizer of this new
larger collective it immediately begins
to distort the action space for all the
nearby cells it starts putting out all
kinds of signals you know reward signals
and and physical forces and all these
other things that now
are going to bend the uh the option for
all the other cells and the best example
of that we have are these zenobots where
the these things are just made of
embryonic skin cells and if you look at
a standard old embryo you get this idea
that well what do skin cells want to do
they want to be a passive
two-dimensional layer on the outside of
the animal they do nothing except sit
there keep out the bacteria you know
nice and a boring two-dimensional life
but what you find out is that that's
only true because the other cells are
basically bullying them into it left to
their own devices with the in in the
absence of these instructive
interactions with the rest of the embryo
what they what the skin cells actually
want to do is get together into a
three-dimensional uh kind of ball-like
architecture they are self-motile that
you know they'll run around and move and
do very have various behaviors including
make copies of themselves if provided
with materials and so that is completely
um
kind of obscured by standard development
where what you're seeing actually is is
cells in a space that was really
deformed by by all their neighbors right
and that's you know that kind of process
that that that starts to devel you know
make them make those distinctions where
the embryo
the embryo can tell what part uh what
parts are inside and what parts are
supposedly outside of itself and that
that gets reinforced by all these early
activities
carl or chris do you want to jump in on
that
i think i think we've been describing
cycas that says basically that it's
curiosity all the way down
every system is
trying to figure out what's going on i
was struck with that with this image of
the little cells putting out fingers you
know this is expiration you know sort of
true blue exploration and mathematically
it's simply as
it says it's um
what
what
artificial intelligence um research
aspires to which is artificial curiosity
you know
going out there getting the right kind
of data
um going to maximally resolve your
uncertainty and paint the way the way
forward
and of course it's
intimately related to planning
in the sense you have to um
realize that palpation you know whether
it's a little cell palpating whether
it's failure or podium
um whether it's me palpating my visual
world i move my eyes around or whether
it's the
little baby babbling and palpating it's
cot this this this this palpation
has to be planned
it could be planned in the sense of the
gazelle sorry because it's not the
gazelle the cheetah chasing the gazelle
so it doesn't have to be very
sophisticated cognitive conscious
planning but certainly has to has to be
planned it has to have this
curious behavior um i mean it you know
it strikes me that that is such a
fundamental
um aspect
that i think
would qualify
behaviors
that have that aspect as cognitive in
some sense and it's so fundamental
because of course it's it's just an
expression
of
dynamics that apply
to
action upon the world
um
that
underwrite
everything that we do as certainly as
scientists and one could imagine as as
human beings but certainly as scientists
you know that the maths of curiosity was
was actually worked out um by dennis
lindley in the 1950s
um in terms of expected information
gained and then reintroduced by people
like david mckay in the context of
active learning so bringing this active
notion that you can learn by actively
acquiring the right kind of data that
optimizes that kind of learning
and it became known as
the principles of optimum bayesian
experimental design
so it's exactly the same kind of
curiosity that we as scientists use all
the time whenever we design an
experiment it's basically configuring
actively configuring
some process to generate something that
can be sensed or measured
that
that maximally resolves our uncertainty
or affords the greatest amount of
information so i mean you know
the three of us as scientists have
become um
experts uh this kind of formal curiosity
simply you know
just by acquiring uh knowledge about
in the in the particular paradigms or
setups and the fields that we find
ourselves in the right way to do
experiments but you could argue that
that's life
you know in a sense that is the the
infant bubbling uh it is you know
that kind of sense making and getting
actively getting the right kind of data
to work out your place in the world
uh to work out what you know what you
should do next
is one of the most existentially
important imperatives um and you know i
was struck
by the mechanics that mike was talking
about in terms of the you know
the little skin cells left to their own
devices having a party and forming balls
and wandering around i mean you know one
could apply that kind of mechanics
to people can't couldn't you or even
even cultures and countries we're all
trying to find our place and we're all
trying to work out how to respond to
those constraints
people around us at many different
scales um
um you know put on our behavior and try
and infer well how am i meant to behave
in this situation
so even if we all start off with the
same genetic code and the same sort of
model of you know
how people behave
the context in which we find ourselves
now needs to be inferred in order to
have to know how to behave in this
context either with a child or as a
mother as a politician or as an age
worker or a first responder whatever you
want you have to make that inference and
of course that inference
inferring that context requires
the curious behavior that
that
that chris had picked up on
in mike's example
wow
could could you know what i'd love to
hear is uh each of you talk about um
what is the
simplest most basic uh
thing so you know hopefully going down
to like
physics prior to life but but whatever
you like what is the most basic thing
that is able to do that because that's
what i find in in talking about this
stuff to other communities the thing
that people are the most resistant to is
this idea that these kind of dynamics
this this kind of exploration curiosity
prediction all of these things that
we're talking about that you know people
people think it's it's brains first and
then you can do all these these these
great things i i would love to hear um
you know what you think is the simplest
physical system that can do that kind of
thing so that we can talk about how far
down it actually goes
while chris is thinking about that with
a profound answer
not a trivial answer but a formal um
answer uh i i think it's
um you'd have to identify the um the
depth of planning
um
that underwrote the
the dynamics of the behavior of the
system
[Music]
in question um and that would be
basically
if you were putting this in a sort of
path integral formulation it would be
the sort of the the amount of time over
which you are integrating your paths and
you're evaluating the best way forward
um
once you move
once you move from uh very short time
scales
um
then the depth of that planning
i think eludes um physical realizations
that could be written down in terms of
um
representations in terms of
concentrations and
depolarization and the like um and one
has to move to a quantal discrete time
representation so you know
i guess i'm basically making the
difference between the sort of um
the
the the kind of dynamics you'd find in a
in chemotaxis or a thermostat um
that could be written down as
differential equations in fact
the kind of differential equations we
used in one of those early
pattern formation papers and knowing
your place uh approaches um where
everything could be articulated in terms
of differential equations so that there
is a kind of planning but it's not on
the curious kind that we talked about
it's just following the most likely
paths of at least action so i would say
that they're not cognitive in the sense
that they they have planning
um so i put chemotaxis and thermostats
and possibly most viruses probably at a
pre-cognitive
or proto-cognitive level
but as soon as you get to
um
[Music]
generative models that can roll out deep
into the future and i i repeat this when
you try to implement this in silico you
you're using computer simulations you
really have to move to a discrete time
representation
um which i think is a non-trivial thing
i mean just for example remember the
sort of the eye movement example yeah we
sense make by getting little snapshots
of the world every 250 milliseconds
uh it's not like i've got i am a
thermostat and i'm taking a continuous
record of the temperature that is a
continuous i'm actually getting discrete
quantal observations
and i think once you move to that kind
of generative model or biophysics that
entails um
the gradient flows under that genitive
model
then i think you're in a position to
talk about sort of planning and
cognition and curiosity of the kind that
we were talking about
uh so i you know i'd literally put time
constants on this i'd say about you know
300 milliseconds if you've got the
ability to represent the future
300 milliseconds and
you know
sorry represent the consequences of your
actions more than 300 milliseconds in
the future then i put you in you know
having crossed that
one of those cuts
and and move from from being a sort of
um yeah
a virus to to you know to to i don't
know perhaps an insect i'm not sure
that's purely empirical so you know
the facetious aspect inherits from the
fact that that's that's very egocentric
it's just for things like me i don't
know if it's the things like cells or
quantum physics well it's interesting
because in physics the number three has
an interesting role in fundamental
physics because there's three
generations of
of matter and there's that number three
crops up and it's a mystery as to why it
sounds like the number 300 or 300
milliseconds a unit attached to it for
neuroscience maybe a fundamental
constant so chris
what are some of the deep thoughts that
you were having
well i i was just having a visual
impression actually when mike was
talking
and
um of of babbling
and
the visual impression was of our our
sort of model of the quantum vacuum
and
when we think of when we think of the
vacuum
or at least i think of it
visually as little things popping in and
out of existence all the time
and
so
one can think of that as a as a kind of
babbling right the the field itself is
exploring what's going on outside of
itself
that's extremely interesting
by
forming a little entity to go off and
explore and then report back
so this is a this is a very different
picture from the one that that
carl gave
in that
um
but i suppose it also has a similarity
or two
that
when we write down
uh a model of that activity it is
discrete
it is operating in a discrete kind
by generating discrete events
even though it's it's modeled in a
continuous spacetime which
uh
once one digs a little bit deeply the
continuous space time itself becomes
discrete
but
this raises a question for me
which is another of the things that i
think about a lot
um
which is the question of
what we mean by randomness
and
certainly to take a bayesian point of
view where probabilities are all
subjective
it becomes very difficult to say what
randomness might mean if if used in a
way that's meant to be objective or to
refer to something objective
and we model things like
fluctuations in the vacuum as
random
which from a bayesian point of view just
means
it's uncertain to us it represents
information that we
don't have and quite possibly can't get
even in principle
but if we think of that system
as an agent
then of course we're expected to be
exploring its world whatever it is
whatever
uh
exists that's not it
and
maybe how we can really think of
babbling all the way down as a model of
of what's happening in
these phenomena that we
persist in thinking have is random
but we also
don't typically think of these sorts of
systems as agents
this is this is this is incredibly
interesting um
what i heard what i heard carl
saying among other things is that there
is a there is a qualitative transition
when things go from analog to digital in
a certain sense right from from from
continuous to to phase and based on what
chris just said it would just remind us
to to think about the kind of the
quantum world where
at least to my understanding a lot of
things are in fact uh you know sort of
discrete does that mean that really
could it be that that that is the sort
of base state as chris just outlined
with with with that kind of uh
proto-cognitive exploration all the way
down and that these continuous models
that we put on top of it by by by coarse
graining um you know tiny events into
the kind of macroscopic things that we
see here that's that's an abstraction
that sort of loses the essential uh uh
mindfulness of it and then we have to
try to rebuild it again by the time we
get to brains but actually all we've
done is obscure the the fact that all
the way from the beginning it was
already digital to start with and we
just sort of put some put some vaseline
on our lens here you know to make
everything look um you know sort of
continuous which then which then made it
look like there was nothing going on at
the lower levels and then somehow we're
we're shocked that we have to recover it
from from somewhere later on
that that's that's what i just heard
from the combination of those two
explanations
it's a very interesting idea and it
connects nicely to the history of
mathematics
or at least the history of mathematics
post descartes and leibniz
which was
all built around the idea of continuous
functions and analysis and calculus and
so on
very very nice convenient mathematics to
use
but
uh
obscure it to the surface